armé de bottes de bâton de
l'indispensable paniers en osier et de
couteaux ils étaient une vingtaine à
l'affût ce matin là au carrefour des
bourbiers en forêt de rambouillet
l'objet de ces intenses recherches
étaient là tapi à l'abri des fûts le
champignon reconnaissez ça c'est une
amanite une amanite et qui a une volvo
là bas donc à manier de pauvres mannix
triaire qui est comestible cuites mais
bon
flasque la manière que je sentais
meilleur au programme qui est de moutons
chanterelles en tube amanites fauves et
autres l'acteur ait reçu de tout poil on
indique aux personnes un itinéraire et
ils viennent à chaque fois que le trouve
un champignon intéressant qui viennent
et puis on leur explique pourquoi
s'est-elle champignons trier répertorier
classer ce matin là nos passionnés
trouveront pas moins de 70 sortes de
champignons ces derniers peuvent être
mam launay déroulé visqueux velouté mais
il y a plus d'espèces non comestibles
comestibles alors méfiance
et mieux vaut se fier aux extrêmes
chaque fois j'apprends à reconnaître
deux prochains viennent plus et puis la
cdu mais alors là il se laissera plus
mon pas comme estime aujourd'hui le
champignon justement que j'essaye de
garder pour les regards des prêts à nous
voulons vivre et pour apprendre à
connaître edison j'aime bien déterminée
chercher comment elle fait des avec des
plantes chercher à savoir ce qui s'est
fait connaître leur nom puis bien sûr de
temps en temps on trouve qu'ils sont
bons à manger et havrais entre fans en
extraordinaire comme certaines espèces
telles que cette sorte de petits calculs
mais il s'agit bien d'un champignon tiko
à jour mon cal auxerre puisque les
poussins sous les pins nous comestibles
celui ci alors quelles sortes de
champignons trouve-t-on actuellement
dans les forêts et blinoise des tensions
nées sous les feuilles ou sous les
conifères
là on est sous les pins sylvestres on
trouvera je dirais pour trouver des
brèves mais on peut trouver
j'irai des différentes monique toutes
sortes de reçus il sous l'effet l'on
peut trouver en ce moment pas mal de
scènes la saison de la cueillette des
champignons touche à sa fin mais la
prochaine sortie est déjà organisée pour
5 10 novembre dans la forêt de bois
d'arcy